[Music]
so how do we get to where we are so
Google's big it's not really a surprise
but we have hundreds of buildings we
have tens of millions of square feet on
all of our offices and all of our labs
and we have difficulty managing that
right so there's existing tools and
platforms have difficulty scaling data
standardization and practice is
difficult and so what we've done is
we've built tools that allow easy fast
and accurate commissioning at scale
because when you think about it you know
building management today is really fun
right and the answer is not really so we
built this platform in order to manage
our buildings better and fundamentally
we want to run Google on Google right so
we want to be a customer of ourselves so
that we can show this is how we manage
our data and our buildings so we want to
be able to access our data we want to be
able to analyze it and we want to be
able to act on it so today we're going
to talk about the platform how we built
it some of the data science behind it
and then we're going to show you a
little quick demo of the kind of
applications that you can build on it so
today when you're thinking about bidding
building management there's really sort
of three personas but the first one is
if you're a landlord or the sole tenant
all right so you're caring about things
at scale you may not care about an
individual building but you care about
how for example the energy spend and the
space utilization happens at scale and
why this building is working better than
that building right you may also be the
facilities ops manager that's a little
bit more focused you care about a
particular building or a particular
campus and you want to know how you can
actually operate it better you might be
dealing with trouble tickets you might
be doing truck rolls in order to do
maintenance and so forth right and then
there's the occupant right so all of you
here today probably work in an office
and you care about having the building
be comfortable you care about the
facilities being
you know able to let you get your work
done efficiently effectively and
comfortable so what's the opportunity
here well so first is energy that's the
first one that anytime someone's talking
about smart buildings they really sort
of hone in on right you want to be able
to use less energy and you want to spend
less on it and that's the I don't think
we really need to go into too much
detail about you know sort of the
motivation behind there it's both on
costs it's not efficient see it's being
more green right if you're on the
operational side you know I don't think
it's uncommon to say that people really
get alarmed fatigue right if you have
anything to do with operating a building
you know that there are literally tens
of thousands of alerts that come in
either weekly or monthly that are just
routinely ignored you don't have the
time to be able to dig into the ones
that you really have to take care of in
order to address issues that you have
either with occupants or with your
facility overall and they hide
efficiencies that you might otherwise be
able to realize if you were able to dig
deeper and then on the productivity side
answering hot and cold tickets that
means people are uncomfortable enough
not to be able to get their work done
and they're telling you about it if
you're managing the facility and
moreover you know Google has tons of
buildings some of them are very complex
layouts people have a lot of meetings
and we have found that people actually
spend and this is a measured amount
millions of hours searching on the floor
for the meeting room that they need to
get to now there may be the issue that
you're having too many meetings that's a
separate discussion but fundamentally
you need to be able to get people to
where they need to go faster and then
there's something that it's very
important I'm not gonna be able to go
into too much about it today but it's
cyber security you want to make sure
that the devices that you have and it's
a growing set of them in your building
whether that's HVAC so
climate control whether it's occupancy
sensors whether it's different kinds of
alarms for you know water life safety
that kind of thing
all of them are safe and they're
communicating in such a way that they're
only communicating the way that they
should and that somebody isn't going to
be able to you know compromise your
network through your air conditioner
right so there's lots of stories that
you've heard about that in the news and
we don't want the systems that we're
building over here to be one of those
vectors so our platform is really to the
to the rescue and you know the the none
of it really is we want to have the
ability to stop having people be your
censors right you want to be able to use
sensors that you have in the building
and you want to gain the intelligence
from that right so on the energy
efficiency side you win and be able to
gather and aggregate all your data you
want to be able to use machine learning
ml to detect anomalous behavior so that
you can address it on the efficiency
side you want to be able to filter all
of those tens of thousands of alarms
that you unfortunately aren't able to
get to to get to you know the small
number of them that you actually want a
dispatch attack or dispatch a truck to
actually take care of and when you have
people who go on-site to address these
issues you want them to be better
informed you want them to know where the
devices are what's actually going on and
what could be the root cause of causing
them to malfunction the occupant side
you want to be able to not wait for the
trouble ticket to open up you want to be
able to detect that something is bless
you it's sufficiently howtube and to be
able to you know proactively address it
and you want to be able to definitively
get people to where they want to go
right so they shouldn't be lost they
shouldn't waste time where you know
you're waiting for that last person to
show up for your discussion or your
meeting and then on the security side we
want to be continually monitoring these
devices to make sure that they're only
communicating in a way and only can
- the devices that they're supposed to
be and like I said you can talk more
about that afterwards if you're
interested in that particular aspect of
the presentation
so today's building management systems
are really siloed right they've been
around for a long time but fundamentally
you're going to have for each one of the
different silos whether it's a V or
energy or lighting or security they're
gonna have their own UI they're gonna
have their own stack their own storage
which may be on pram it may be in a
third party cloud it may be through you
know an API to access the devices
they're gonna have their own networking
requirements and they're really they're
separate right they also tend to be very
rule-based they don't tend to be
learning so it makes it difficult if you
get your rule set up just so for one
building to be able to take them and put
them into another building it's
basically a lot of walled gardens and
that that's problematic right and today
you know it's also sometimes difficult
to be able to take all of these separate
silos and combine them into a more
cohesive orthogonal platform where
you're able to access things and apply
the same kind of intelligence to one
system as to another so what's our
approach this is the platform that we
want to build it really orchestrates all
of this together and you know it starts
with the fact that we want to be able to
take any kind of device like I said
whether it's a climate control whether
it's a sensor whether it's security and
think about it in sort of a orthogonal
way right so we want to be able to have
an API that your mental model of how you
think about all these is the same so at
the bottom you have your devices and
your network and your connectivity so
you know fundamentally that's not what
we're going to go into we assume that
you're going to have some kind of a
gateway you can have some kind of IP
connectivity so that you can talk
through these devices and communicate
with them and they're going to use you
know any kind of industry standards
Modbus back that etc to communicate with
you and we're assuming that you have all
of that set up that's kind of a you know
standard understood way to do things but
then on top of it what we're going to do
is we're going to take the data from
each one of the devices and put it in a
data layer
when I say data lake to you that means a
lot of things to different people but
fundamentally to us it's a time series
database stamped for each one of the
devices and done in such a way that we
understand the ontology the relationship
of the devices to each other have
generalized them to different classes of
devices and we're able to access them in
a structured way all right sometimes a
data Lake can be thought of as just sort
of a collection of data but here you
know we're putting order on top of it we
do that using a building ontology and
metadata about each one of the devices
and char Belle we'll go into much more
detail about that later and another
thing that we do which is I think a
little bit different than other systems
is we have spatial understanding of
where these devices are where they are
in relationship to each other for maps
for the building so that not only do we
know what the device is what it's
connected to its relationship to other
devices but where it is as well and of
course none of this would be useful
unless you had API is in order to access
the data and we do so using the same
kind of mental model that you do for all
of the other Google cloud platform
stacks and technologies that we have you
know this is something that we did
because it makes sense to do it in a
standardized way so that other
developers who are developing apps on
top of this are able to access it in the
same way that they do any of the other
cloud platform technologies and
altogether this is what we're calling
the digital building platform right so
taken all together that's sort of the
the special box that we had black box if
you will that takes in the data on one
side and provides it to applications on
the top so this is where we've built
some third we worked with some third
parties to take their existing systems
that do things like alarming and
analysis and so forth and they use our
platform as the source of their data or
we also have some groups inside Google
that have built first party applications
to do things like anomaly detection
and alarming as well so how do we are
grown a building now what is on boarding
me so I'm boarding for anyone who set up
a building automation or a building
management system is taking your devices
and being able to talk to them and
getting them connected into whatever
kind of management software excuse me or
platform that you have and it usually is
a very painful process sometimes it can
take days sometimes it can take weeks
well with the platform that we built we
started there and it actually did take
us on the order of days or weeks on
board building but we actually got it
down to the point where we can do it in
a matter of hours for most of the
buildings in Google which is a pretty
big impressive thing right so we start
where you either have greenfield with
your new devices or brownfield with your
existing devices and those devices might
be individual so they might be something
like you know an air handler they might
be something that you think of you know
sort of in aggregate together where you
have different component devices like a
B a B or something like that inside of
it and you think of them as one all
right and then we create an idealized
representation of them right so you have
one where you think of each one of the
classes of devices in a way that it
encompasses all of the special fields
and data points that each one of the
manufacturers devices might have in it
but we do it in such a way that you can
address them orthogonal right so you
don't have to worry about what brand
this is what type this is and so forth
and so if you've ever dealt with these
devices each one of them has data points
that's a piece of data and a tag that
basically says what is this what does it
represent what units are it in and so
forth and in the idealized
representation we have the same thing
and we do this in such a way again to
make it so that you can treat all of the
devices in a particular class the same
and then we need to figure out for each
one of these data points what semantic
tag what what tells you what this data
is and what what it represents what unit
it has and so forth right so for example
this might be a tag that you
in the actual device and here are the
different semantic tags that we might
break it down into because we can do
clustering and matching to basically say
we recognize this kind of device in this
set of points that it has and this is
how we map it to a set of tags and then
basically we have a mechanism that we'll
go through and do that matching for all
of the other points and tags in the
system and that way it saves a lot of
the manual work that you used to be able
to do have to do before to do it in a
more automatic way and then of course
you have the api's to access it on the
top and then the applications right so
in whole this is basically what the
stack looks like after you've gotten
something on boarded and into the
building system so what do we do with
all this once you're done it's all great
to have the data but unless you actually
make use of it you know it's not that
interesting so just as an example
particular problem that you might face
is you know an outer set point
temperature right so if you look at the
box in yellow that's what the data looks
like you know raw coming from the device
and it says that this is a sensor that
should be in the range from 62
fahrenheit to 72 Fahrenheit it's
currently 81 degrees so obviously that's
problematic right this has landed in the
data Lake the sensor data captured the
data and it put it in there it TEKT it
with a timestamp right none of this is
really unusual if you've dealt with any
typical building automation system
before but we also have the ontology in
the mapping which tells you where the
device is what type it is what kind of
really sorry what kind of class it
relates to and allows us to get more
contextual information about this
particular error such that when we then
dispatch someone to take care of it
they're able to have more of this
context and hopefully are able to
address the problem faster than the
other
what so the whole is greater the sum of
the parts and you can use all of these
kind of sensors together to tell sort of
an aggregate story now I'm going to
switch over to char Belle is going to
tell you some of the data science behind
all of this platform Thanks
so I want to talk about how do we make
sense of this data as Mark mentioned
before we have all of these silos that
are really in verticals where the data
is trapped so if we take a step back we
have really different devices and
systems that are provided by various
vendors and if they can vary by
geographic region or by country because
no single vendor can can cover the whole
planet and as we mentioned that data is
trapped in silos we saw we have the
lighting we have the cooling the badge
axis reader all of these data are really
in vertical and of course when we're
talking about the building it's a whole
ecosystem so we need to do data
correlation for better management if we
know that the space is not occupied we
don't have to clean it or maybe we don't
have to cool it or maybe we don't have
to light it so all of these simple
information can give us a lot of
insights to better manage space and of
course we want to be able to correlate
the data so we can serve it for these
three personas whether you are a
landlord an occupant or a facility
manager so one of the ways of doing that
is by relying on ontology so before I go
through it by show of hands who heard
about this word before okay
so an ontology is a common vocabulary to
refer to the concepts in a building but
we can also use it as a way to express
relationship between these concepts
don't frown upon this definition I would
go through more details so this is
something we didn't invent it started
with the Greek philosophers when they
started to map the world how a mammal
can relate to a human how does living
being as related to the planet and all
of that and of course computer
scientists like to reuse things from the
past so computer scientists reused
ontology as a way to represent
information it can be also in a building
so in a simplified definition an
ontology is just a way to represent
domain concepts and the relationship
between these concepts as they are
usually represented in triplets and we
distinguish between classes and
instances so you can see we have a city
and a country which our classes are
connected by is located n which is a
relationship and then we have the
instances like Paris is located in
France what is nice about ontology is we
don't need to invent how do we represent
them because the World Wide Web
Consortium already proposed
standardization like RDF our are in
json-ld to represent and Express these
kind of relationships so let's take an
example in a building we have a location
which is a concept we can have
subcategories like a building floor and
a meeting rooms that are also connected
together and we can also instantiate
them with a room a floor and a specific
building so this can be seen as one of
the silos and we also have another silo
which is the devices we have a sensor
that is measuring a quantity a
temperature sensor measuring a
temperature and then we have the
instances so as you can see thanks to
the ontology we can link these two silos
together by adding relationship and
connecting them together so there's a
lot of ontology is out there we didn't
want to reinvent the wheel at Google so
we looked at what is out there
I'm gonna focus in the following just on
three of them and as you can see with
the cloud tags there's really a lot like
saref and KNX m2m ontology I'm gonna
focus only on three of them so the
haystack vocabulary started in 2014 and
it was one of the first effort that said
okay I'm gonna start proposing a
vocabulary for my building domain and
this is where we started to see these
tags emerging so it's a tag based system
similar to the Twitter hash tag where
for a certain point like a temperature
sensor one you
sign one or many tags together so it's a
tag based model it's not an ontology and
back in 2014 they didn't rely on w3c
consortium but they had their own zinc
standard another interesting progress
was provided by Siemens in 2015 which
points out in a research paper the
limitation of haystack
the lack of expressivity ambiguity and
assigning tags you can imagine that you
cannot express relationship with just
tags it becomes really very hard to
manage and of course you need an
abstraction when you do queries the tags
are a very flat system when you are
trying to query you might want to query
by location or by an upper class so you
lose that with the tags because they are
flat so Siemens proposed a haystack
tagging ontology which proposes to mix
between the haystack tags to semantic
sensor network ontology and the building
models like BIM and IFC so basically
what Siemens tried to do is to take
these flat tags and represent it in two
triples but that you can see it's not
really a lot of explicit relationship
just to add hashtag and The Triplets we
still lack of explicitly and this is
where bricks come into the picture so
the brick schema proposed by IBM and
several academic universities which took
into consideration haystack haystack
tagging ontology and serif and proposed
the models that is I would say richer
than just a simple tag model and it's
also relied on a pragmatic approach they
took around six buildings that are
scattered across the globe that they've
supported different vendors and they try
to refine what are the concept or the
common concepts of these ontology and
they proposed break what is nice about
brick is that it's not
out there it is part now of the ASHRAE
body to propose which trying to push
brick to become a standard so this is a
really an interesting thing for if you
are in the buildings domain because you
can go and influence this vocabulary and
this ontology and of course brick schema
guided our choice for our digital
building platform because of its rich
richest Ness and that it builds on prior
work related to the ontology so now that
I've talked about how do we represent
information I would like to talk what
are to talk about what are the bricks
that we used to that we reuse from GCP
to build this platform so we have a
cloud IOT to connect the devices to the
cloud we have pops up which is
publish/subscribe mechanism we have data
flow for bash and streaming processing
and BigTable and spanner for storage and
then I'm gonna show a little bit a
simple chat pods that we built in a very
quick manner to show how easy it is once
you have the ontology and this API is in
place how easy it is to tap into the
system and extract what kind of whatever
information you would like to have so
first I'm going to talk about cloud
about IOT core it's a fully managed
service for you to connect your devices
and systems to the cloud and as you can
see on the architecture diagram you can
combine it with different other
components like pub/sub data flow so you
can collect process and analyze your
data so far in the Bay Area we have
around 100 buildings that were on
boarded and we have around 20,000
devices that are connected along with
120 thousand points that are publishing
data to the cloud so once these devices
are connected and are pushing telemetry
data to the cloud
we rely on pop sub which is an
enterprise oriented middleware it's
secure scalable and globally distributed
where you have a topic and multiple
subscriptions that can collect data for
you so far these devices send
approximately four million messages per
day so which is kind of a lot just to
give you an idea about the scale that
pops up can handle once this data comes
in - pops up you can see that you can
have different mechanism to start
playing with the data do some batch and
stream processing on it and this is
where we use data flow because it really
it gives you a unified batch and
processing service it relies on Apache
beam which is an open source programming
model so you write your logic once and
then you can pick whatever running
environment you would like so it can be
sparked or it can be as well dataflow
the cool thing about dataflow it's a
fully managed unit you don't need to
scale it and so it's hustle free and of
course it's very scalable that support
million of queries per second so
dataflow is grabbing the data from pops
up and then doing the processing on it
and putting it in BigTable which is a
fully managed no sequel database for you
that can handle up to petabytes of data
sets and it's ideal for Internet of
Things data like the time series
currently we store around 500 gigabytes
of data coming from our buildings and as
I mentioned we we have only 100
buildings on-boarded today and then my
favorite is bellick flow
Valek flow allows you to build chat BOTS
or interactive agents that rely on
really the knowledge of Google when it
comes to the machine learning expertise
related to NLU it supports multiple
channels you can do chat you can do
voice whatever channel you think about
you can integrate it and it's one of the
most widely used tool to build actions
on top of the Google assistant so I will
go through the demo a little bit
oh I can't argue so as you can see here
we have a user which can be one of these
three personas it can be the landlord
the occupant or even if the facility
maintenance operator that will interact
with the chat application that will help
the facility's board which will interact
with dialogue flow to interpret whatever
the user input was and then the
facilities bot will actually handle the
call with the api's so created a little
video demo of course this is just a
proof of concept to show what is
possible but you can stretch your mind
to support any type of operation based
on the data that we have in our
buildings
yeah I just wanted to make it high
quality Thanks
so what you will see here is the user is
just typing queries to count floors on a
certain building so the beauty of that
is that once we put this in place we can
change the building and tap to any
building that Google is operating so it
can be in Cambridge in New York it will
not change how we deal with this query
and this is thanks to the ontologies but
also they kept the capacity of dialogue
flow to interpret the query you can
search for meeting rooms information
such as I want to count how many meeting
rooms do I have or I want to just see
them I want to see the largest meeting
room because maybe I'm hosting an event
and I would like to know where should I
book I can change sides and if I'm
maintenance operator I would like to see
it and understand where are these HVAC
components because when you are the
maintenance operator usually you are
walking into a building and all of these
components are hidden for you behind the
ceiling so you don't see any pumps you
don't see any fans you don't see any of
these HVAC components so you're like ok
I need to find them I need to locate
them and this is where the maintenance
operator can use similar capabilities
with a chat bot to understand where is
the device whereas this equipment I need
to go replace where is it located so
here we're still targeting the floor
level but you can imagine we can show a
map and guide the maintenance operator
to go and look up where he needs to look
to prepare the environment for him so we
can locate a fan because he need to
change this type of equipment we can
group them by floor because he would
like to run some diagnostic operations
on them and benchmarking benchmark them
by floor and how they are behaving and
here we can see more queries related to
the HVAC so these queries
and the keywords that you are seeing
like the fans the palms the fanboys are
all taken from brick brick schemas that
we talked about earlier because brick
allows to lay the foundation of this
vocabulary so we took these vocabularies
and put them here and of course for some
who don't want to type we have also
interactive menus where these queries
can be already populated and the
operator need just two a header button
or click on one of them so that's it for
the demo so of course this was just a
proof-of-concept to show what is
possible on top of this building
platform I think I'm stuck on ok thanks
I think it's okay it's just one slide
thank you so another example is also to
extract time series and integrate them
with the chat board or maybe integrate
them in another third-party application
so that's it I will pass the mic for
mark for the conclusion thanks well I
hope that gives you a little bit of an
idea of what we've been building with
this platform and what it can do you
know this really is sort of a work in
progress for us for how we manage our
own facilities at Google but it really
you know is meant to show you some of
the themes that have you know been
pervasive I think you know throughout
the conference here particularly you
know we're doing this for ourselves on
our own stack right and it's basically
showing that you can build these kind of
rich applications using a lot of the
capabilities that Google already has so
you know it's modernizing an
infrastructure that frankly you know
hasn't been changed in many decades
right so you're seeing a lot of new kind
of analytics and applications and
platforms sort of at the top level but
we're sort of going very deep into this
stack all the way down to the device
you're seeing that we're using these
building blocks in GCP as basically a
way to build an application platform all
right so you're utilizing and not having
to reinvent the wheel as Charbel
mentioned for a lot of the capabilities
in building out these applications and
we're also going from analytics to
action right so we're using capabilities
like machine learning we're using a lot
of our data visualization and so forth
to be able to take that raw data which
is sort of difficult to maybe discern
messaging and action from and do the
analysis to be able to come up with a
punch list for text or operators to be
able to go take care of
our onboarding process really is I think
leaps and bounds ahead of what it takes
to do onboarding and typical systems
today and this is sort of where a lot of
the intelligence is being developed
right now you know as we go into new
buildings and discover new types of
devices new kinds of network topologies
new kinds of gateway boxes and so forth
you know that's helping to make this
platform richer so that the next time we
encounter it it's much quicker to be
able to onboard it's really you know
building out the fundamental
intelligence of the underlying system so
that it actually applies down the road
as we go along and we're using
structured data here so we're trying to
use you know the best of what the
industry is working on right now in
terms of ontology in terms of
terminologies so that an operator will
be able to take the you know lessons
that they learn in one building and be
able to apply them into an entire campus
or other buildings as well so what next
well that's where you guys come in we'd
really like to continue the conversation
particularly if you have device data or
interesting ways of representing data so
we touched mostly on things like climate
control HVAC today but I mentioned that
there's a lot of work that we're also
doing for things like occupancy sensors
and alarms and physical security and so
forth so if those are the kind of
devices that you work with we'd like to
know how would that integrate with this
platform what would you be able to do if
you didn't have to do all of that
plumbing down at the bottom of the stack
but we're able to just apply whatever it
is that you do best at the top for
applications on device security and
maintenance you know I touched on this a
little bit at the beginning but you know
we have been talking in the open-source
community about how to do continuous
integrated testing of your devices to
make sure that they're only
communicating you know with the devices
that they need to in the way that
they're prescribed to and that's
something that we'll be talking a little
bit
more publicly but essentially this is
something that we want to do at Google
as well to be able to ensure that our
network remains secure as well and then
again the third-party apps and other
integration partner involvement and so
forth remaining involved with the
various standards bodies and like you
know ASHRAE a brick haystack and so
forth and if you have involvement there
as well we'd certainly like to hear you
know whether or not what you're doing
sort of integrates well with what we're
building with this stack so that we can
make sure that when we encounter your
devices out in the field hopefully we
will that we would be able to integrate
with them as well
[Music]